laberge merci d'être avec nous que se
passe-t-il tout d'abord à kiev alors
très clairement la pression militaire
s'accentue sur kiev même si elle est
lente parce que ce convoi nous sur les
cartes c'est que la situation n'a pas
beaucoup évolué tout simplement parce
que les ukrainiens résiste je vous
propose de regarder tout ça en images
voilà la carte de kiev avec donc ces
trois angles d'attaqué de l'armée russe
d'abord à l'ouest au sto mail butch à
irbine où se trouve notre envoyé spécial
butch à vous le voyez est à nouveau une
ville disputée les combats dans cette
zone sont absolument incessant de
l'autre côté de la rivière brovary le
front est de la capitale les forces
ukrainiennes ont gravement endommagé une
colonne blindée russe ça s'est passé il
y à quelques heures vous le voyez c'est
très clair sur cette carte l'armée russe
en fait tentent d'encercler la ville
mais du coup elle est dispersée et elle
est ralentie à l'image de ce convoi
militaire dont vous parlez dans vos
journaux que l'once avait bloqué au nord
de la ville cette fois depuis quelques
jours et bien qui s'est redéployé et qui
sait dispatcher lorsqu'il faut
comprendre elles nous disent les
analystes militaires c'est que les
forces tout simplement l'armée russe
manque d'hommes pour kiev tout
simplement parce que les soldats russes
sont occupés plus au nord à
à kharkhiv pardon et à
pjanic pardon et a soumis ce qui fait
que tout simplement il ya un effet
domino une fois que ces deux villes
seront tombés et bien l'armée russe pour
art dispatcher des hommes sur kiev et
rendre la prise de haine la capitale
possible donc tout simplement pour faire
court judith l'armée russe n'a pas assez
d'hommes ce qui explique aussi peut-être
cette déclaration ce matin de vladimir
poutine qui valide l'envoi de
volontaires en provenance notamment du
moyen orient et la russie élargi ses
attaques en ciblant de nouvelles villes
oui ça c'est la stratégie russe les
frappes se déplace vers l'ouest avec des
nouvelles ville qui n'avait jamais été
frappée auparavant là aussi on va
regarder ça sur la carte vous allez vous
avez la ville de l'us ici vous voyez que
c'est très près de vivent là où beaucoup
de gens sont réfugiés vous avez aussi
ivano francis et puis vous avez n'y ait
pris si ce qui s'est passé c'est que
globalement des aérodromes militaires
ont été visés un aérodrome local lutte
et une usine de moteurs à réaction de
mort des soldats et puis six blessés à
nieppe les bombes sont tombées non loin
d'une crèche d'un quartier résidentiel
et d'une usine de chaussures c'est ce
qu'on nous dit ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que cette ville là elle
est pleine d'industrie lourde y compris
une usine de fusées alors c'est
intéressant pourquoi ce matin parce que
ces frappes là et bien elles sèment la
terreur et le trouble là vous avez des
images de ce qui s'est passé à nieppe
elle sème le trouble parce que les
ukrainiens je vous le disais se sont
rassemblés se sont réfugiés à l'ouest
pour essayer de d'échapper à l'armée
russe et la voilà ce que l'armée pour se
mettre en sécurité
une députée ukrainienne disait ce matin
en réaction à ces trois nouveaux
bombardements il n'y a plus une seule
ville sur ici en ukraine et c'est
précisément ce que veut faire l'armée
russe sur le front est karkhiv la
deuxième ville du pays elle est
également fortement bombardée oui tout à
fait elle est bombardé jour et nuit avec
ce chiffre assez frappant
89 bombardements sur karkhiv en 24
heures c'est ce que dit le gouverneur de
la ville mais la russie alors karkhiv ça
se situe ici vous voyez de très lourds
bombardements
c'est donc sur ce front est les russes
la russie n'a pas encore lancé d'assaut
terrestre sur karkhiv à grande échelle
ce qu'il faut c'est que il bon bah pour
tenter d'encercler est de prendre la
ville alors vous le disiez karkhiv c'est
un point stratégique pour les russes
c'est la deuxième un grande ville
d'ukraine et vous le voyez elle est à la
frontière car qui vit ici avec la russie
ce qui explique ces violents
bombardements au sud deux cars qui vont
à regarder toujours sur cette carte
idiome points stratégiques où les russes
également intensifient leurs opérations
pour tenter de stopper de s'emparer de
trois villes qui se trouvent au sud 10
youm par ici et on a appris que les
forces russes auraient bombardé un
hôpital psychiatrique
cette fois près de la ville d'izu
malheur ce qui se passe c'est que les
forces russes veulent se déplacer vers
le sud l'objectif vous le savez bien sûr
c'est de rejoindre les forces qui
avancent elles vers l'ouest à partir du
donbass et puis informations importantes
ce matin la ville ici de vol novak a qui
serait tombée aux mains des russes merci
beaucoup marina bertsch pour toute
précision merci à vous parler